what's up
guys bang bang it's lunch
money time well wall street's trying to
get rich wrestlers just try to get a
lunch money right
as you can see we ain't at home
don't worry we're in a safe safe
place covet free don't forget that lunch
money's not sponsored by block five
block five has three products you can
buy and sell crypto on a crypto exchange
you can deposit crypto and earn
up to eight point six percent a p y in
their interest bearing account
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral go get a block fi account
blockfy.com pump blockfy.com
blockfi.com what's up
my hair is being weird again um hi hi
guys
what's up okay um all right
so utopian ideas are being tested in
europe is the pandemic
gives governments a new role i thought
this was really interesting
christine jardine a scottish politician
who represents
edinburgh and the uk parliament was not
a fan of universal basic income before
the pandemic hit
it was regarded in some quarters as a
kind of socialist idea
but not long after the government shut
schools shops restaurants and pubs in
march
with little warning she started to
reconsider her position
kovit has been a game changer she said
it it has meant that we've seen the
suggestion
of a universal basic income in a
completely different light
in her view the idea sending cash
regularly to all residents no strings
attached
now looks more pragmatic than outlandish
i kind of think it's a kind of a power
grab but what do you think
are you kidding me are you kidding me
oh i used to think it was a socialist
idea but now that the
in ep government is literally
being complete idiots now all of a
sudden it's not a socialist idea
this is socialism knock it off you know
what we should do
we should tell the government to shut up
get out of the way
inform people with information and let
them make their own decisions
we have politicians career politicians
that are killing small businesses
in la right now they have decided that
if you are a restaurant you must shut
down
whether you have indoor or outdoor
dining so all of a sudden now the virus
is
back outdoors what is going on right now
uh i know politicians are idiots
these people are incompetent they
literally are career politicians
they spend their entire career as
politicians that should not be allowed
you should not be able to spend your
career as a politician
you know why because you're dumb
literally you're dumb you've never had
the feedback loop of when you make bad
decisions that
there are consequences and so what we're
seeing right now is literally
politicians are killing small businesses
and also politicians are violating
people's rights
how many times do we have to determine
that lockdowns and shutting down the
businesses are unconstitutional
there's been multiple rulings in the
united states on this already
and then on top of it now all of a
sudden it's given the excuse of like oh
let's just give everybody money
what how about this idea
hey people wash your hands wear a mask
socially distance don't go near other
people make sure you avoid the virus
we need to get rid of this thing but
there's going to be a vaccine
we're going to reach heart immunity and
it's going to be okay the world's going
to keep spinning
on top of that you are responsible for
you you need to build your business you
need to go to work you need to do things
that you need to do
because the government's not coming to
save you this idea that the government's
coming to save you is what got us in
this mess it ain't going to get us
out i know the plan i don't like when i
say this but i'm telling you
the government is not looking out for
you
look out for yourself my my thing is
that
socialism has been tried we've tried it
many a time
many a time it has not led to great
things
maybe learn from the past all right
apple anti-socialism
anti-socialism if you're a socialist
sorry
not really apple has agreed to pay
millions of dollars to 34 states over
its controversial previous practice of
deliberately slowing down
older iphones to extend their battery
life the company will pay 113 million
dollars
to settle an investigation by states
including california and arizona
over how apple was not transparent about
its iphone battery problems that led to
unexpected device
shutdowns everybody's been speculating
on this forever
here we are battery problems that just
got you to upgrade the battery problems
always strike right when they come out
with the new item called battery gate
yeah battery gate how about purchase
gate they just needed you to purchase
the new life
what does this mean so apple's settling
but does that mean it's going to change
its practices
that's a great question i'm sure that
people could be paying attention a
little bit more now
do you think that they were doing it
intentionally or do you think it was a
battery problem
i think they thought this was a great
growth hack
like oh i have an idea it's just so
interesting new iphone gets announced
my phone starts slowing down damn i
wonder why
i think one time we watched the daily
show with uh trevor noah and somebody
made the joke that
if apple came up at the time apple was
talking about like coming out with its
own cars
and it was like god if apple had its own
cars you'd have to upgrade every year
with a new model because otherwise like
the the little the electric thing that
you charge with would be a different
plug and then and then the old cars will
start slowing down
so now all of a sudden they're gonna
sell you the car there's gonna be no
plug you have to buy the plug separately
jeez all right what's next elizabeth
holmes
what is she doing well so right now
she's trying to block
jurors from hearing about her luxurious
lifestyle when she was there no ceo
she's trying to block federal
prosecutors from introducing evidence of
her wealth
spending and luxurious lifestyle to the
jury
uh her trial began or will begin on
march 9th
2021 with jury selection uh basically
she employed personal assistants to run
her luxury shopping sprees traveled by
private jets they did exclusive hotels
and drove an expensive suv i feel like a
lot of so okay so a lot of ceos do that
but the fact that she's trying to block
it i think is interesting
um and yeah she's facing a slew of fraud
charges in prison
her defense attorneys don't want her
wealthy pass to be played played out in
the courtroom
yeah i mean look it it
is uh i mean i get the point i get the
point of like her wealth and her
spending
doesn't mean she was guilty it also
doesn't mean that she's innocent either
but she also i think came from a wealthy
family so you don't know how much of it
was there
versus you know something else look this
stuff is always hard
because um there's not a ceo
in america that has some level of
sophistication that doesn't have
somebody do something for them now are
they considered an assistant
are they running shopping spree errands
or are they going and getting
coffee for the office or are they going
and bringing some of the post office
like what's business related what's not
like
there's a bunch a bunch a bunch of
nuance here
we don't have all the facts it also
depends like what types of funds were
used was it her personal funds that he
she was using or was it the company or
et cetera and like expensive suv
well like a suburban was an expensive
suv
depending on who you talk to or also a
rolls-royce suv would be expensive you
know what i mean like what's an
expensive suv and so i think that
like the fact that uh she's trying to
block it does
speculate that maybe it's you know not
so great
um at the same time though like i do
think uh
there is this world of like you have
fraud charges
and how much does that play into it
i don't know we don't have the
information so it's hard to she faces up
to 20
years in prison if convicted what do you
think is gonna happen
i don't think she'll get 20 years but i
i do think they're gonna try
and kind of it's gonna be harsh in my
opinion
there's a quote this is the jury should
not be subjected to arguments regarding
mrs holm's alleged purchase of luxury
travel
fine wine or food delivery to her home
attorney said
if all of a sudden you get when i get
dominoes delivered does that make me
luxurious
it does not it's certainly anthony food
delivery to her home i get food delivery
i get
dominoes i'm luxurious anthony be
hitting people with
oh that's not my lifestyle that's not my
scene
yeah i hit somebody with that yesterday
they were talking about a fancy
restaurant i was like that's not my
scene
so yeah next charlie dimillio
tick tock influencer she is the first
tick tock influencer to hit 100
million followers do you know
how much uh that's a lot of people the
population
of bulgaria is like seven million do you
know how many bulgarias that is
a lot wow
so she only started posting last may
she's bigger than the rock on tick tock
well of course she's the biggest
um and so in a year and a half basically
she almost exactly 18 months she
garnered 100 million
followers i actually really like charlie
she's very
i think down to earth even though recent
scandals have tried to discredit that
i think she's really down to earth she's
16 right she's 16.
can you um if i had 100 million people
paying attention to me when i was 16. oh
my god
oh boy get off the internet it would
have been
wild imagine if me and all my brothers
had a hundred million
a hundred million forget a hundred
people forget a hundred thousand you
would do crazy stuff for 100 people
100 million people we'd all be dead are
you kidding me we'd be dead
all right ready you want to see how fast
i can go on this car
you want to see how quick i can do a
wheelie on this motorcycle
dude let's shoot each other with
paintball guns at point-blank range and
see who cries first okay
why are you so much more tanned than me
that's so weird it's because i have all
of sky
i have all of skin from the i have olive
skin uh sorry i'm from the mediterranean
region i am from the met well the
balkans but close
yeah all my skin you guys are white
arctic people
you're not we're hot blooded you should
see me fired up
all right are you i've seen it it's not
something to celebrate that is that
alexander
the great blood from macedonia
i don't know alexander the great got
killed let's go no but he like
took over all right um not the italians
ah i actually don't know somebody
fact-checked that but i'm pretty sure
the italians
yeah they're wrong anybody who's got to
name themselves alexander the great
ain't probably ain't so great that's
like me walking around being able to
think he doesn't pop the king i don't
think
they pop the king i'm pumped the king
you're like okay he's not the king
obviously
she is um yeah guys i did get a haircut
if you're wondering okay
come on come on okay um
okay there's a new program called tulsa
remote
that wants to pay you ten thousand
dollars to move to oklahoma and work
remotely
pass why okay how about this you move to
oklahoma
and take the 10 grand i'll stay in new
york city
the program wants to attract talented
and energetic people like us
to tulsa who care about making a
difference in their local community i
think that's a great idea
very smart economic uh development uh
program
i will not be participating why uh
because then you
it sounds great oh you you if you move
you get ten thousand dollars sweet
and then you move then you're like oh
but i live in tulsa oklahoma no no
offense to anyone in tulsa oklahoma
by the way i love oklahoma oklahoma is
awesome have you been to
uh i drove through one time i loved it
it kind of reminded me a lot of like
wyoming montana that whole
uh area but tulsa oklahoma is not for me
for other people that want to live there
vibrant
people talented energetic people okay
now if you were talking about giving me
10 bitcoin we could maybe have a
conversation oh really you would move to
tulsa for 10 bitcoin
and then i would leave yeah with the
bitcoin all right
patrick from the uk i think hi pimp and
pump
i'm pimp i think loving lunch money a
recent fine for me i'm looking to invest
in bitcoin but worried about the
vulnerability to hackers or just losing
my keys
what's your thoughts on investing
through an etf
thanks patrick if the question doesn't
cut it here's a joke
i was just looking at my ceiling not
sure if it's the best ceiling in the
world
but it's definitely up there i like you
patrick patrick
but when it comes to bitcoin good
question uh
if the way i would think about it is um
what are you trying to do if you want to
own the bitcoin for a really long time
you should get
possession of it um and you should
control your keys
in order to do that there are some
fairly simple
products out there ledger casa there's a
bunch of others
but that's a pretty easy way to get
control of your keys there's tons of
tutorials online just
google it or look on youtube if you just
want financial exposure
and it's something where you're like hey
i'm going to basically trade this i'm
going to buy it
i'm going to sell it when it goes up or
something like that an etf
actually hasn't been approved in the
united states at least but there are
other vehicles like gbtc and others that
you can
use to get exposure um they're fine if
you just want the financial exposure you
don't actually want the bitcoin
i think most people in the bitcoin
community would argue though like not
your keys not your coins and so
holding the private keys is advantageous
cool thank you patrick
kd do we think this is kevin durant no
kd asks why does pump care so much about
the price of bitcoin if he doesn't plan
on selling
ah see here's the key thing you need to
understand
about price price is merely a scoreboard
and when the price goes up that means
the bears were wrong
bears and that's why i care is because
that's what everyone pays attention to
as some um the media pays attention to
the price a lot
yeah as some uh signal for progress
for value uh i personally don't care
right
literally i just think it's hysterical
that when the price goes up a bunch i
can talk [ __ ] on twitter basically
i mean that's literally what i do i wake
up and i'm like oh wow we broke through
18 000.
sweet firing off tweets but when we
break 20
when we break 20 i will say i have a
list of people
that i am going to tag and i'm going to
go one by one
and i'm gonna remember i got receipts
these clowns
they were saying all kinds of stupid
stuff well when i'm gonna bring the
receipts out it's like when i go to the
store and i return it what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna go back and i'm gonna
return all the [ __ ] they talked
i'm gonna return it to them and i got
receipts and they know who they are
they've deleted tweets and all stuff i
got receipts you just watch
20k get on the internet and get your
popcorn when bitcoin hit
18 000. he was walking around the
streets of new york like screaming and
yelling and singing
all right vanessa do you ever use that
coffee machine in the background or is
it just for show
starbucks wants to know hey vanessa
don't be hitting us with rap lyrics
so we we got that as a gift or is it
just for show starbucks wants to know
yeah he's turning into a song we've used
it i've used it you've used i frothed
with it um but starbucks is kind of nice
we have this like little ritual where he
goes and gets me coffee while i
am still sleeping and then he brings it
to me and then i wake up
okay wait okay now it's in all
seriousness uh we've used it a lot
actually
uh i don't actually like the coffee that
goes through there well because the
coffee
is not perfect yeah so we get a new
coffee but also
uh the there's uh
the people who own the starbucks near us
uh it's a franchise
and so uh i like them and i try to go
support a little bit
okay and i get yes it's a starbucks and
brand and all that kind of stuff but
there's there's a uh husband and wife
that own the starbucks
um and so i like going and helping them
great final quick story can i tell them
about the bath mat
sure i mean this is absurd i mean
men out there men out there by the way
this is a perfect uh
reason as to if you're thinking about
getting married it may make you second
uh have second thoughts
i did not know that but um
[Laughter]
i ordered what i thought was a super
absorbent
um bathmat and it was marketed as such
and it was off the internet off the
internet
and the reviews were incredible and
people are like this is the best
bath mat i've ever set foot on i was
like i'm so excited
we get this massive by the way men just
in case you don't know a bath mat which
i didn't know what that was
uh it's the thing that goes outside of
the shower so when you open the shower
that you can step on this bath you know
what that is i did not know that so i
thought that was called
the shower carpet so we get the shower
carpet
but like the box is really heavy i was
like i wonder
how they wrapped this and so
so we opened it but i didn't tell him
what was in there and he goes why did
you get a cutting
such a large cutting board in coasters
and i was like what are you talking
about
we pull it out it is hard as a cutting
board
and it came with a piece of wood i put
she got a piece of wood for me when i
get out of the shower naked to step on
and absorb the water how the hell is the
wood going gonna do that all right guys
that's it this is absurd we're done i
literally got wood underneath my feet
when i'm naked and
toweling off ain't getting afraid put
that image in your head
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends